our political editor Beth Rigby is in
Downing Street with that breaking news
Beth
yes Dermot it's literally just landed on
Twitter Android Letson the leader of the
house the former Environment Secretary
the woman that went up against her
resume in the 2016 election to be the
Tory leader has quit cabinet her letter
has literally just dropped on Twitter
and she says dear Prime Minister I'm
proud to have served you in your
government fast as environmental sector
in the last two years as leader of the
House of Commons she said she's grateful
for the opportunities she said she's
stayed in cabinet to shape and fight for
brexit there have been uncomfortable
compromises but she goes on to say I no
longer believe that our approach will
deliver on the referendum result for the
following reasons I do not believe that
we will be truly sovereign in the United
Kingdom through the deal that is now
proposed I've always maintained a second
referendum would be dangerously divisive
and I do not support it there has been
such a breakdown of government processes
that recent brexit related legislative
proposals have not been properly
scrutinized and the tolerance of those
in cabinet who have advocated policies
contrary to the government's position
has led to a complete breakdown of
collective de-spawn sibility she then
goes on to say there are important
elections tomorrow many conservatives
have worked hard support our excellent
panda dates I considered carefully the
timing of this decision but I cannot
fulfill my duty as the leader of the
house tomorrow to announce a bill with
new elements I fundamentally opposed I
fully respect the integrity resolution
and determination you've shown but she
says I have with great regret and a
heavy heart I cannot carry on in your
government and she has resigned so there
you go the bomb has dropped the Prime
Minister was meant to see David Mandel
today she turned him down right at the
last moment she refused to see Jeremy
hunt the Foreign Secretary she refused
to see Jeff sad to Javid the Home
Secretary all coming in to try and tell
her that they would not support her
brexit bill they would not support
the withdrawal agreement because and
Andrea Letson picks up in that letter of
resignation they could not tolerate the
idea of the Prime Minister even toying
with a vote on a second referendum or
putting that into legislation it was too
much in the end for Andrea led 'some to
swallow and she has gone tonight and
you'll know that she wants to run as
Conservative Party leader she will throw
her hat into the ring for that
leadership race so perhaps she is now
going in the hope that that might bring
in some followers behind her testing the
temperature of the party and the anger
amongst fractured tears over Teresa
May's fourth attempt to get that brexit
bill through look we knew really that
the Prime Minister was going to pull the
boot bill but Andrew led some now making
life a number-10 very difficult for the
prime minister indeed